[Music]
hey you guys it's monday yeah we're
turning around like pookie's like i'm
gonna tear up the [ __ ]
okay so 24-hour party people it's a good
movie it's about the uh manchester scene
uh with joy division and even mentioned
like the sex pistols and susie nabanshi
and all the all the [ __ ] players that
were in that scene and
you know like mostly the money guys the
guys who had the money and tried to put
all that stuff together
it's comical and it's historical and a
lot of legendary [ __ ] happens in it
they [ __ ] weave in actual footage
it's a good flick i liked it this is
actually
probably one of my favorite movies of
all time um
i guess
one of the reasons i really like it
because i don't know like if you're not
really
into uh post punk or kind of like the
rave scene that kind of came out out of
manchester england in the early 90s then
you might not get as much out of it well
goth on the side too but yeah that as
well so um where i came from yeah so i
kind of feel like that's probably why um
i'm super into it because you know that
whole manchester scene there's so many
like manchester bands that i was into
like joy division and the fall and the
smiths and stuff like that another thing
i liked about it is that they talk about
the evolution of nightclubs
yeah because a lot of [ __ ] i took for
granted yeah because i i lived through
it
i forgot how it used to be
like my uncle read he came up in
nightclubs that were centered around
music scenes in other words bands
uh if you didn't have bands you didn't
have a [ __ ] club
they found out later when rave happened
and i kind of forgot about that bands
kind of vanished
because you didn't need them they were
just an unnecessary overhead
uh who became famous was the dj the dj
the club with them and and his set
which we got maniac in they hit the rise
of the dj it was a [ __ ]
a good
film for explaining this kind of [ __ ]
uh
to to people that are like in their 20s
and 30s
i told nick about it he was oh yeah i
got to see that i heard about it
and he just takes it for granted that
nightclubs involve dancing and
djs yeah well no is that like that but i
forgot
i forgot yeah this does it good i mean
the movie i really kind of like
the way because this is a very sprawling
topic i mean pretty much
but i like the way they filtered all of
it kind of through tony wilson because
tony wilson who was a real guy he's
passed away
but he was a tv presenter
uh in the
uk and he kind of became instrumental
because he got so into the burgeoning uh
punk and post-punk movement after seeing
the sex pistols in manchester in
1976 and he kind of used his tv show
which was just kind of local to the
manchester area as a platform to show a
bunch of bands that weren't really
getting any traction like in other on
other tv shows or other radio uh
stations in the country so he was kind
of like instrumental in doing that and
he got so into it
that
he started a record label
and then later on also uh ended up a
co-partnering in a
club which later became the hacienda
uh where kind of was the birth of rave
culture in the late 1980s
and so he was kind of like so i like
that they filtered it through that now
this movie too so like i said it's very
like anarchic
it does have real [ __ ] in it uh and it
actually weaves in kind of real
footage like real footage of the sex
pistols that manchester like lesser free
trade hall real stuff of like you know
the buzzcocks and the stranglers and all
this other than susie and all this kind
of stuff so they weave that in there but
they kind of make it you know but they
then they kind of like put in the
fictional stuff as well they also bring
in real people from those bands and
weave them into the fictional story like
you know playing roles
yeah you know what i mean like [ __ ]
bell hops and [ __ ]
or whatever yeah
drains it's kind of funny because
um
well some people are in there like
playing themselves like mark e smith
from the fall uh has like a cameo he's
just kind of playing himself like he's
in the line like waiting to get in the
club or whatever
but they do have like a lot of like the
real tony wilson who steve coogan plays
in the movie
uh he was actually has a cameo as
the i think he's like the director of
the producer of like the wheel of
fortune show so so he has like one scene
and then they have howard devoto from
the buzzcocks and magazine and he's kind
of like playing like a janitor like
cleaning the bathroom yeah uh so does
one of them play a a [ __ ] conductor
rail car conductor was that one of them
rail car conductor oh yeah yeah
that's right yeah yeah that was actually
oh i can't remember who that was
that might have been paul ryder like
from happy mondays but i could be
remembered it wrong
because it's funny but this movie
it's very postmodern in the sense that
it's
reality but also legend
uh interview uh interview and stuff like
that and it also like breaks the fourth
wall so you're basically having steve
coogan as tony wilson
talking to you the audience and so and
also acting as though yes this is a film
you know what i'm saying so he so he
goes back at some point he's like
there's a lot of real people in this
like it and he'll go back and like show
the stills of like hey this is so-and-so
from whatever so you know i like how
they did it it's basically kind of like
how they did it in goodfellas he's
telling you his career how he got to
where he got
remember how good fellas was yeah
breaking the fourth wall and talking to
the to the audience he does all that
and um
tells how he kind of
went from a television guy into a club
guy
and how [ __ ] stupid they were when it
came to money uh which is the [ __ ] it
wasn't so much stupid
he knew and he just didn't care
he was kind of like it's funny because
even though one of my favorite things
about this movie is that one of the
marketing things
uh has like a picture of sean harris who
played ian curtis and it said genius on
it and then it had a picture of the guy
that played sean ryder from happy
mondays and said poet on it and then it
had a picture of steve coogan playing
tony wilson and it said [ __ ]
which i thought was like really really
funny he he was a good he was a cool guy
but man he's wasting 30 000 on a table
yeah
sending [ __ ] bands who were drug
addicts after the [ __ ] barbados and
gone for [ __ ] two years they gave him
200 thousand pounds that's all they did
was buy drugs
yeah and then oh just dumb [ __ ]
not having not having any of these bands
on [ __ ] proper
[ __ ] contracts and then a company
just shows up and wants five million
dollars to buy factory records and it
goes well i can't sell to because i have
a contract and just well he's like i
don't have a back catalog
and i don't have any contracts to sell
you which was struck
man that 5 million would have saved the
club you know and there was just a lot
of stuff and those bands would have been
better off in the hands of somebody else
probably um somebody would crack their
whip on them
and
but you know they just didn't take it
seriously uh yeah and as i said i kind
of feel like his whole thing was one he
was very very averse to selling out and
he just cared about the music and the
manchester scene and he just wanted to
disseminate the music because he thought
it was important his thinking was wrong
though but i mean
right but you could unders you could say
that like he was almost kind of like the
distillation of the punk rock attitude
because he completely did not care about
the money but about money at all he just
cared about
the the artist he wanted them to do what
they wanted to do like i said it
probably didn't work out so good in a
lot of cases because like i said you
know some like the sean rider from happy
mondays they sent him off to barbados to
make a record and he spent it all on
drugs and he didn't do any vocals and
all this other kind of this yeah and
that was money that could have gone to
the club and things to [ __ ] make more
albums or get more bands the bands would
have been better off if they had
somebody who was [ __ ] harder on them
probably or you get rid of them one of
the two and replace them with another
bed that could do something
um
and then even if you're harder on those
bands they end up making more money so
they're richer and they have more
product to put out he just didn't really
have a business mindset but he's
admitted that in the movie well yeah
like i said that wasn't really his goal
and honestly you could argue that people
nowadays are still talking about joy
division and still talking about factory
and still so so he was actually
successful in the way that he wanted to
be successful yeah you know what i'm
saying like people still remembered it
and it was important answered some of my
questions about ian
curtis and [ __ ] joy division i didn't
imagine him
being like that he was kind of hostile
um
well i imagined him being kind of quiet
but he was
he was but it depended well he was a bit
lavish which a lot of people were in
manchester at the time because they were
all just kids i mean they were all
working class you have to think that ian
curtis and stuff like that like when
that happened like when they first saw
the sex pistols they were only in their
teens yeah like like late teens if you
never heard any uh joy division go
listen to it go like level tears apart
or tr [ __ ] transmission or something
and uh
or
listen to the [ __ ] closer album which
is why it's really good and it when you
listen to those lyrics you in that voice
you think a wise old man is talking to
you not some
kind of dumb kid but it sounds like a
[ __ ] wise old man yeah he wasn't dumb
but he did have like a lot of problems
and honestly
yeah but
the thing about it uh is i think a lot
of that could be attributed to i mean he
was just like a melancholy person all
around must have been some kind of
mental problem uh no well what it was
mainly i mean there was a lot of other
factors
uh if you've ever what if i mean this
movie it's it kind of skips over a lot
of stuff if you want to see something
that's just about joy division there's a
movie called control which is actually
really good this one kind of is more
focused on like it's a lot of stuff
about joy division it does cover his
suicide and stuff like that but
um it's kind of about the whole scene so
they're kind of like in the first half
but then it goes on but i read his
widow's uh
book
and one of his major things there was a
lot of things going on but one of his
major things was that he had really
really bad uh epilepsy like one of the
most severe cases that the doctors had
ever seen
uh and it really started getting bad in
1978 to the point where uh not only
obviously was he not allowed to drive um
he every time he performed they couldn't
have flashing lights obviously because
it would trigger a seizure pretty much
every time uh so if the lighting person
wasn't on board with that and started
doing flashing lights he would you know
he would uh have a fit and he would like
fall over sometimes like certain
percussion like when uh also cause him
to have a seizure one time he had a
seizure in the bathroom and hid his head
on the sink and it knocked him out and
they didn't know where he was
uh they even advised him like when he
had his baby daughter they said we would
advise you like not to hold her because
you could have a fit and you could drop
her on her head so
uh so they were trying to like figure
out what medication to
you know
because they said pretty much this is
gonna impact your whole entire life like
we can give you some medication and it
will maybe
help you but
this epilepsy is like really really bad
and this is gonna like pretty much
haunt you your whole entire life
and it was it was getting worse like as
time was going on and they weren't
really uh
figuring out and the drugs also had
really bad side effects like it was uh
he couldn't really sleep all that well
it was doing like these really big mood
swings it was doing all this kind of
stuff so i'm sure that really
didn't help
uh you know like i said there was some
other stuff going on like his wife had
just filed for divorce uh because he was
having an affair allegedly um and she
told him she would give him a chance
like hey if you don't like have contact
with her anywhere she was a belgian girl
um then i'll
call it off but you know there was so
that was that
and like i said he just had a baby i
don't think he and they were gonna tour
america like he actually like hanged
himself uh on the night before they were
gonna go to america he thought um
according to people that knew him they
said it wasn't so much that he was one
he hated to fly which i get but he
thought that when he got to the us and
started doing shows that he would have a
fit on stage and everyone would laugh at
him
so
there was that as well so he was he was
really really um sensitive about it
uh because he thought it made him look
ridiculous or whatever so he had like a
lot of uh problems and what they didn't
say this in the movie
but he had actually attempted suicide
before
like um
about like a month or six weeks or
something like that before he actually
did it
um he did attempt suicide before and
tony wilson and his wife or girlfriend
at the time lindsay who they've
portrayed in this movie um they actually
let him stay at their house for a little
while
and kind of like we're talking him down
from that so they knew that he was
you know that he that he was in danger
of doing that but the thing about it
like i said this is the late 1970s or
1980 when he did it and
mental health kind of stuff it wasn't
really something you talked about like
even the other band members in joy
division were like they were just kind
of kids too and they're like well we
didn't really know how to help him and
it's like and he was trying to make it
seem like it wasn't as bad as it was
so whenever we asked him like we were
worried about him like he just said no
it's no it's fine so i don't think they
really understood like the depth of all
the [ __ ] that he was going through
because it just wasn't something that
that young dudes talked about like young
working-class dudes talked about they
get into the band new order
slightly in this which uh came from joy
division
in some ways new order i think might
have been better
uh it was recorded a lot better i mean i
like joy division better i mean i like
new order too i mean new order were
massively successful like you know
probably way more i think joy division
was more influential i don't know it's
kind of hard to say it's kind of true
was darker it was more like yeah it's
two slightly different kinds of music i
guess but yeah uh yeah one of the funny
things that they say about it is that
you know when blue monday came out uh
the 12-inch single
and they said you know it was the you
know biggest selling 12-inch single of
all time but because of the of the
design of it
which was supposed to look like a big
floppy disk which uh a few kids today
don't know what that is but uh it's
supposed to look like a big floppy disk
so it had like a cutout in the middle
and it was just like had this big
gatefold it was a beautiful cover
um
but they say this movie is like we lose
what five pence like every one of these
we sell just because the
just because the uh graphic design on it
was so expensive because of like all the
cutouts and everything like that but
they that was one thing where tony
wilson just like he liked the design so
much that he didn't care that it cost
more
to like print it and make it
than they made off it when they sold it
because they sold like a [ __ ] ton of
them but yeah it's just kind of the same
thing about when he opened the hacienda
which at first when he was having bands
play there
you know it wasn't really you know
they'd have like three people show up or
something like that but
for whatever reason there was all this
kind of like synergy when rave first
started to come around in the late 1980s
when he got happy mondays involved and
everything like that and the members of
new order uh also had a lot of money in
that club as well
and it all just kind of came together
and then the play start was like the
place to be like in manchester and then
it was [ __ ] packed and it was just
kind of like the kind of ground zero of
the rave scene and that was essentially
where
like you said the nightclub where
everybody's cheering the djs rather than
bands everybody just went to dance and
actually but the club even though
zillions people showed up
kept losing money because everybody was
on ecstasy they weren't buying buying
drugs from illegal drug dealers and they
weren't buying booze yeah uh so that
caused a lot of problems so they had a
lot of people in there but they weren't
drinking so they weren't like and also
it uh you know they had a lot of gang
violence uh later on and stuff like that
you know because of all the drug dealers
coming in and shooting one another and
[ __ ] like yeah they couldn't they
couldn't uh they couldn't keep the drug
dealers out and they were afraid to turn
the drug drug dealers away they're in
england and they got they got guns so
the security isn't armed so they can't
well i think sometimes they made some of
the drug dealers like the door guys yeah
like because they were trying to
mitigate
the problem somewhat
because they did kind of try to do it
but like i said it they weren't real
they didn't really care about like the
bit well he didn't i thought the
funniest thing about this and i was the
unsung here everybody in this is good
steve coogan is [ __ ] hilarious i mean
he started as a uh he's a lot better
known in britain when this movie came
out than he was over here because he had
the allen partridge show where he plays
a character that has like a talk show
but i think this was america's first
like widespread uh you know uh
movie that they'd seen him in
but i want to say one of the unsung
heroes of this movie
is
patty considine who plays rob greton who
was joy division and new orders manager
that dude he was like the tall dude with
the glasses that dude is [ __ ]
hysterical in this i kind of wish
because he's
sort of like the voice of reason like
the whole hilarious thing when they
finally opened factory records for a
long time factory records was just like
a thing it was just like a collective
they didn't have offices or contracts or
anything like that
um so finally tony wilson like way in
the late 80s decides he's going to open
up an office and he gets this ridiculous
table stupid ass that's like
it's like this red like lucite i don't
know what it is but it's like this
really long table it's all like wavy and
[ __ ] yeah it's got a [ __ ] and it's
got like
metal wire that looks like the golden
gate bridge
and like he shows everybody in there
he's like look we finally have offices
and stuff and everybody's like oh that's
quite a table and he's like how much did
you pay for it and he says 30 thousand
pounds and there's a pause that's like
60 grand and then rob gretton likes
runtime and it's like
actually
like that and they're trying to break
the fight
which is [ __ ]
i would have done the same thing man
60 000 it would look like a piece of
[ __ ] all right it looked like something
that you
look like something in a cheap [ __ ]
cheap studio somewhere cheap art studio
with axel foley walking around in it
beverly hills it's obviously
something made out of nothing you know
what i mean you could put it together
for like maybe a grand couple grand how
to [ __ ] [ __ ] from the hardware store
that's what it was yeah i'd have kicked
that motherfucker's ass sixty thousand
well yeah that's what i just think
that's funny because rob gretten was
just kind of like
in a business that's basically going
under and not really just barely
treading water you know i had to kick
his ass yeah he's crazy he was great
crazy
he was a little bit [ __ ] crazy but he
was very very aware and yeah he had he
was forced to walk away from a 5 million
5 million pound offer that's 10 million
yeah london records was going to buy
well they were going to buy out the
whole yeah because they wanted they
wanted happy mondays yeah but the 10
million you could have taken and just
reinvested into a [ __ ] huge business
because they didn't have 10 million in
that and he had he had the street cred
to attract on all new regime
of bands
you know he could have done it again
you know a lot of dudes do that that's
how or they could have just retired the
rest of his life yeah i mean like i said
he had money they would have had to
divide it up he had money because he was
on tv like so he still had and he was on
tv like the whole yeah and that's a
pittance so yeah but i mean he had a so
he had his own money but you know what i
mean he's lucky to make a couple hundred
thousand hundred thousand a year yeah he
offered him [ __ ] 10 out of 10 million
dollars but yeah 5 million pounds is 10
million dollars
i don't know how much it was back then
but yeah that was probably in general
talking about the 80s late 80s
early 90s yeah i think it was i think a
pound was about two dollars or a dollar
seventy-five something like that
i mean but i would have been frustrated
you know yeah well yeah like i said i
think a lot of people were but right
it's just kind of like
i just really liked because he's
he's just such a lovable character in
this because like i said he clearly does
not know anything or he i guess he knows
about because he doesn't really care one
way or the other i mean like at the end
when they when actually the hacienda got
uh repo'ed and they were having their
big last night there was like a big
party and like at the end like when the
guy came to repossess it he says to
everybody he says
invade the offices and loot
take it all
because they were like taking it all
away but it's just like he was just um i
don't know like i said he just thought
that it was like
he says at the end he was explaining
that his his big sin was like civic
pride because he loved manchester so
much
uh and he really want and he thought all
this music was important that it was
gonna you know resonate throughout which
it did i mean
he was right about that and i thought it
was cool i mean this movie was directed
by michael winterbottom
and uh written by frank control boyce
who are both also from manchester
and i believe steve coogan is also
originally from manchester as well so
this was just kind of like a real
homegrown
uh you know every everybody there was
kind of like oh you got to check your
chicken yeah but um i mean seriously
but yeah i do love patty considine in
this i kind of wish he'd been it a
little bit more
but just because he's such a good foil
uh
for steve coogan's character i mean
that's just like the conversations they
have are just like so [ __ ] funny just
and he just has like impeccable
comic timing you know what i mean like
the very very last scene where they
after he's lost the club and he's kind
of lost everything and they're all just
like oh whatever and he's up on the roof
of this building and it's uh him and rob
greten and like the two guys from
uh happy mondays and they're up there
like smoking weed that sean ryder got in
barbados and
there's a great scene at the end where
tony wilson sees god except it's him but
it's like floating up in the sky and
he's got like a big gray beard and like
[ __ ] on it he's got like all this gold
[ __ ] behind him and he tells him like
how uh you know he was the guy that did
all this stuff and blah blah blah and
then
so then like tony wilson turns around
and the other guys because i've just
seen god and they're like what and he's
like yeah i just saw god they're like
what do you look like he looked like me
he was like the spitting image of me and
then he says something like um
he says well does not say that in the
bible it's like a god created man in his
own image and then there's a pause and
then rob greton goes
yeah but he didn't say a specific man
it's just like the tone of his voice is
just like so [ __ ] perfect but i don't
know there's something like i said
there's i think i really really like
the whole i mean because this is uh
about a time period
that um
that i really am into and a lot of music
that i'm really into so i probably like
like it maybe more than somebody that
wasn't into this kind of music but there
is something just like there's such a
great
energy to this movie like i said it's
almost it's very anarchic i really like
how
it sort of like blends
uh you know reality but also kind of
like legend but it'll tell you like
maybe this didn't happen this way but
we're this is more interesting so we're
showing this instead there's just it's
just got such a great like punk rock
energy to it and you know and it's just
really interesting and i think like all
of the
kind of scenes are very
the way that it's all played is very
very organic and very naturalistic you
know what i'm saying and i just i don't
know i just always really really liked
this movie i liked the other joy
division movie too control but that was
more like i said that was more like an
ian curtis biopic that was based on his
wife deborah as his widow's uh book but
this one is kind of more
sort of based you know what's
interesting i think um
uh tony wilson's wife at the time uh you
know
lindsay who is in this movie well she's
not in this movie but there's an actress
playing her
uh is
she wrote a book with
i can't remember who she maybe it was
mick middles who was also like a real
big he wrote books about the smiths and
[ __ ] like that and they wrote a book
about
this whole time period they wrote a book
about ian curtis and actually i looked
into buying it i was going to buy it
from the uk but it's like [ __ ] 50
pounds and i was like god damn it so it
must be i think it's like a limited
edition or something maybe i can get it
cheaper over here someplace but i would
actually kind of like to read that and
yeah it's
i don't know it is kind of like cool how
they uh
how they kind of like go all into
this and honestly the one scene i saw
this in the theater actually when it
first came out
and the one scene where ian curtis uh
dies what happened i'm just hearing
things over there oh
the one scene where ian curtis dies and
then they're all like at his funeral or
whatever and then he goes in there to
you know to kind of like pay his last
respects or whatever and then atmosphere
starts playing
and then like he just kind of kisses his
forehead and he says bye son then it's
like oh
that makes you so sad but uh yeah so
it's the movie's not set i mean the
movie is actually really really funny
more than anything i mean it's [ __ ]
hilarious the whole [ __ ] about
that whole great scene where they're at
that club and like he goes he goes back
in the in the van like with that other
guy and there's like hookers out there
and he's getting like a [ __ ] from a
hooker like in the back of his van
and then like his wife comes out and
like opens the thing and she's just kind
of like huh okay and then she
immediately goes back in the club and
starts humping like howard devoto from
the buzzcocks and
in a bathroom he goes out there to find
him
[Laughter]
there and there and he goes down the
stall and she he's got her [ __ ] he's
different
and she just looks at him like yeah and
he's he's because what's he he goes into
her purse he says what you got you know
he's looking for the keys looking for
the keys yeah
and then he's hold it against her i mean
[ __ ] and then he says
and then he says um i just got a [ __ ]
that's full penetration okay
[Laughter]
but what can you say
[Laughter]
what can you say that's true
and then on like on the way out like the
real howard devoto who is playing uh
like a janitor he's like cleaning the
sink and he like turns to the camera and
says i definitely don't remember this
happening
but it's just so that's kind of how like
it's very meta and it's very like
self-referential
but
i don't know i just i [ __ ] love this
movie if you're at all into
uh you know post punk or any of the kind
of [ __ ] that happened in england this
does actually even though it's
kind of crazy and
you know sort of melds fact and fiction
together it is actually a really good
examination of
not only manchester almost being kind of
like the the center of the post-punk
explosion because so many bands came
from there but also being the center of
the rave thing which is crazy that it
was like the same city
that was sort of like like i said ground
zero for both of these massive like
musical youth movements
and so it does like a really good job
and it's honestly even though it doesn't
even though it's not like a biopic and
it doesn't follow like little beats it's
kind of all over the place but i think
in a way that makes it a little bit more
truthful is that weird to say like it
doesn't really like stick to like fact
fact fact but
it does kind of like oh and the guy that
plays uh martin hannett in this who was
uh who produced joy division
uh and it was a complete lunatic
and um that was the same guy that played
gollum in the lord of the rings movies
that was andy circus under all that
stuff and then it's funny like he gets
[ __ ] fat at the end yeah and then
and then they shove like he dies he has
a heart attack and like he sticks his
massive [ __ ] coffin
and they're kind of like this and it
wouldn't fit no
dude because he was too big for death
yeah it's so great it's just like i
don't know i just [ __ ] love this
movie i love the whole british sense of
humor i love all the music in this it's
just so fun and like so energetic and
everybody that's into
post punk or new wave or any or rave or
anything like that should probably watch
this because i feel like
it's kind of like required viewing i
hope nick does watch it yeah he's gonna
watch it now he's only he's only like 21
or 22. right that's like our
our friend because or he calls him his
son yeah but yeah he's only 21 or 22 and
uh but he's really really into like old
school like he loves joy division and
christian death and all that kind of
stuff and we were like yeah you got to
see this [ __ ] movie because this
movie is like a [ __ ] it's a blast
it's really really fun and honestly i've
seen it like a [ __ ] ton of times because
i have it
on dvd um but i was like really excited
to get to watch it again because i
haven't seen it in several years and
it's always always a good time
uh yeah fourth row down says peter hook
told the story of how the band were
persuaded by a fairlight synth which was
2 000 pounds in 1982. yeah that's a lot
of money meanwhile he could only afford
to put a gallon of gas in his car per
week damn yeah pretty much
uh you know fourth throwdown also says i
actually went to the hacienda in 1986 to
see the jesus and mary chain oh lucky
you i never got to see that all about
that man i love to jesus and mary jane
and i never got to see them
it was so loud that my ears actually
hurt afterwards i could see that they
were very very loud
band all that feedback
but yeah
yeah all right yeah
uh is the
how long is the food gonna be
um
probably another half hour we'll see
less depends on when i'm down here but
yeah you had a good time with this movie
yeah yeah yeah i liked it so yeah but
yeah if you're at all into british music
from that time period then yeah you
really have to see this movie because
it's super fun it came out in 2002 did
we mention that yeah it came out in
2002. so uh definitely watch 20 years
old
yeah yeah but you know it's still like a
lot of fun and uh yeah i would
definitely recommend it one of my
probably one of my favorite movies of
all time uh never stops being funny to
me so uh yeah uh i guess that'll do it
for today's show i don't know what we're
gonna watch tonight we'll find something
to talk about tomorrow maybe we'll do i
don't know so i was going to say maybe
we'll do another british movie since
we've done two but it doesn't really
matter we can just watch whatever so uh
yeah thanks for dropping by today and we
will see you guys again talking about
another movie tomorrow
bye